what an ex is that's never gonna - okay
now I don't have to do any algebra to
this if I think about this as my
approach
okay which is kind of cool I like that
right think about it this way one on X
what is this shape has a name it's a
hyperbola if you want the technical
fancy name it's a rectangular hyperbola
we'll get to that later
all right now I'm looking at less than
or equal to two
I should probably met with my fixin
asymptotes again I'm not being all that
fussy because this is just a mechanism
for me okay
where's two twos going to be well that's
that point there where these distances
are equal it's gonna be doesn't know the
coil it's that point it'll be one one
right so if that's one I'm looking like
spy satellite so something will
something like this okay
now I'm looking at when it's less than
or equal to that value
okay so again let's take Nikita's
approach okay which parts are okay this
parts okay it's below my two line and
this whole branch over here is also
completely fine okay so without
appealing to any algebra just off the
basis of this diagram I can say right
from the diagram anything again just
like here I've got two different parts
that I'm looking at how would you
describe this part what bounds it it's X
is is a greater on this off it's less
because I'm starting here and going that
way okay so X is going to be less than
zero and I even though I have a boundary
included here I don't have a boundary
here why not right I never actually get
there so I can't say oh it could include
zero too because I can never actually
get a sensible value out of that right
there's one part and then I have another
part right and this time it's from here
going to the right now think it's a very
simple graph
what's the x value that's going to
correspond to that you can almost see it
because I'm drawing it accurately enough
it's a hub isn't it because I said I
plotted that as kind of one right and
it's just the
for a cool function one on X is the
reciprocal function so the reciprocal of
1/2 sure enough is 2 okay so I've got X
is greater than for a reason to a half
that's great right min-soo okay very
good
I could have now I will actually go
ahead and do this if I didn't want to go
and do this graphically right because
sometimes it's not so nice and neat and
one on X you know we've seen one makes
100 times right it's not always so neat
okay it might be shifted this way that
way all that kind of thing so you may
have to appeal to the algebra solve that
so let's see what we would do if that
was the case right away I should note
the restriction the X can't equal 0
but then what I'm running up against is
the problem I had before in order to do
any work on this right I've got a couple
of choices I can try and take her some
reciprocals right because you can do
reciprocals in equations if I said 1 on
X is equal to 5 right all I need to do
on this side here is to flip both sides
I can do that this is X on one and this
will be 1 on 5 so X is 1/5 because one
on 1/5 sure enough a equals twice but
but what happens when you do this print
in equality hmm okay right so if I were
to write if I were to write this let's
flip that okay and then I've got less
than there and then I'll flip this you
can already see because we've worked out
the solution you can see this is wrong
okay so if I'm going to take reciprocals
think with me for a second and you
already know what the answer is if I
take reciprocals what should I do to the
inequality yeah okay
I'm gonna take that as my second
approach I'm going to do that in about
30 seconds all right but if I would just
take this line of argument what should I
do to this side yeah okay so you can
take two cases you can take cases but
just looking at this line of argument
and knowing what my answer is surely I
should just flip this inequality
okay now am I allowed to well let's
think about this for a second it's a bit
tricky because it's algebra we've looked
at we've looked at problem-solving
techniques before right and one of the
ways that you can tell whether algebra
is right or wrong is to think about
whether you can do the same things with
concrete numbers like actual numbers you
know what they are and see if that works
okay so let me give you any example of
an inner column that I know is true okay
come back over here this is stuff that
Oh is true uh-huh
these are not equal but I can write in
equality between notes that would make a
true statement
what kind of inequalities should I write
half is greater than a third at least
last I checked okay now if I were to
take the reciprocal zip both sides the
reciprocal of this sign is two and the
reciprocal of this side is three so
what's happened to my statement well in
order to make it true I'm gonna have to
switch the direction of the inequality
and that's fine okay so can I do this
yes I can because that's how
inequalities work with reciprocals just
like you follow to multiply by negative
numbers right let's go again
well it was actually a sir set to take
this line two less than three if I would
should multiply both sides by negative
one I would write negative two over here
and then I would write negative three
over here what's happened to my
inequality sign it's flipped again in
fact it's kind of flipped back okay why
is that true because that's the way
inequalities what right you can think
about in terms of absolute values right
if you stop a negative sign on it I'm
going further away but in the opposite
direction so that's why it's greater
than or less of it depending on which
values you're comparing okay so this is
fine this is a true statement but it's
not all is it right and it's not all
we've lost a solution haven't we okay so
here's the way you get it back this is a
simplest
way to think about it okay I'm gonna go
to Erin suggestion though the reason why
I'm sort of having these problems is
because I'm trying to work with X but X
is a variable right I try can't just
multiply by X right unless I want to do
two cases avoid cases where ever you can
sometimes you can't but where you can
avoid them so to avoid cases here I'm
going to multiply by something I know is
positive namely x squared okay so if I
multiply this by x squared and I
multiply this by x squared do you see
what we've done okay
we've created now a quadratic problem
and a quadratic problem is going to have
two solutions watch what kind of
solutions we're gonna get what's my left
hand side there what should I do to this
thing put it all on one side okay so at
least on this configuration I have ears
I don't like negatives okay so I'm going
to multiply by a negative one and switch
the direction my inequality excuse me
miss happy so far okay now what factor
take the X out one uh-huh okay so now
you can see this is a parabola and as
with all lot of parabolas it's got two
solutions namely zero and a half a hut
but pay attention okay here's a half
he's zero so what does this problem look
like it's the right way up so it looks
like this it is pretty narrow all right
now look carefully at this with me okay
this is why I'm glad minsu mentioned his
theme first off okay I had this I want
to know where it's above okay so look
here's one part okay which is here yet
increasing the boundary to the left okay
yep and then I've got the left-hand side
as I did before right there big deal aha
except except my very very first line of
working which is exactly right as I
noted there was a restriction before I
did any of this business I said there's
a restriction X can't be 0 because I
multiply through by x squared which
would be zero which would be problem so
being the X equal zero lies within the
domain of my solution I have to take it
out I have to take it out so that's why
it becomes that which is exactly what I
thought it was in the first place okay
does that make sense because this thing
would look like this and I'm looking for
the parts but theythey axis because I
haven't switched the direction
inequality it's all fine
say it's the same question you mean if
I'd done this way yeah yes in fact what
depending on the question the exact
question that I get to pay me ease that
question I guess it would be harder or
easier but this is actually a superior
way to do it
can you see here like just compare the
amount of work just come here any matter
what
admittedly it's because it's a simple
it's one on X so I don't need to do any
work I know exactly what it looks like
okay um but here you've got a fuss
around with the algebra with lots of
places for it to go wrong and then you
have to note the restriction or is here
I have no problems like that because I
knew what it looked like I knew what the
actual question was I didn't convert it
into another question to notice this
question is not this question right this
is a hyperbola and it's a parabola these
are different to make them equivalent
and note the restriction and that's what
takes out the boundary there okay so
this is actually a superior way to do it
but if it's if it's harder if it's
Messier like if it I don't know like if
it's if it's just the numbers making a
bit messy just Messier enough it's like
to be sure I'm getting my right values
because I don't know what 1 over 2 X -1
looks like you know like that takes me
about maybe 30 seconds to make sure I
get the asymptotes right and the shift
in whatever um for that case I probably
do the algebra just to be sure okay
but if you get a question like this and
if it happens all the time
ok there's nothing wrong with a paean to
graphical solution so mr. broth is good
enough to make the solution